right you know you know also you know
that makes sense yeah i mean
they took a lot huh and i'm very frugal
with my money all right i said that word
are you a penny pincher
no i'm not it's good to be it's getting
frugal yeah i'm
very frugal because you know it depends
wait i got what are you frugal
let's talk about it let's not go in the
ocean
so with your xbox check i don't know how
much it was 40
they took out but what what's up with a
new ride
what do you mean oh we got to get you a
picture like brendan had on that uh
porsche
oh oh yeah yeah i'm not getting a
porsche i'm gonna get a tesla you don't
have to get
whoa that's that's your goal i'm gonna
get a tesla you can get a tesla i get a
test
hold on let's talk about you getting a
tesla so you're giving me a tesla
you live in an apartment yeah okay we
can't set up a charging station there
so now it's a tesla in my apartment
building the guy
like yeah yep so now every you're not
gonna charge overnight you have to go
somewhere to charge it yeah because you
don't have to own a home to set up a
charging station
so now you have to go around finding
charging stations into a
stupid-ass tesla
do you ever think about that no i didn't
think about that first of all you ain't
got to call it stupid yeah well
yeah i don't know i love elon musk yeah
i love elon musk okay okay that's not
fantastic so you're not a fan of
okay all right let's put like this but
uh
huh out of all the cars tesla tesla let
me tell you just because it's electric
what's that
i've never seen an electric porsche yeah
i've seen electric i'm not in that tax
bracket yet brendan
i thought we're talking about goals here
are you gonna get the electric porch
yeah uh if i were to get an electric car
that'd be the one i get or the new
hummers electric the h
the new uh i need three hummers
ridiculous h3
malik i thought you wanted to get a bmw
yeah i wanted i saw
i like brenda's that m3 by the way i
don't have a bmw
wait wait me and brynn wait timeout time
i got to call jay out on this
so he listened to the last episode right
and he goes
it's funny how britney said you know he
went from a prius straight to a porsche
out of m6 before that
i noticed i went straight from prius to
portland yes
i came i came to la ina m6
uh a 2006 m6
got it 2006 yeah he said it was hard too
black on black
yeah he said he loved that was the first
like major purchase i got and you said
you went on a date and all the doors was
unlocked
my first day i went out with my wife all
the doors just flew open
really what did you believe i have no
idea how it ever happened couldn't do it
if you asked me to do it again
no idea everything her louis
vuitton bag was sitting in the front no
one with it
off main street in venice but you again
everyone wants to live in the west
side everyone want to live oh yeah now
you do that you do it now
please besides dicey yeah so what
happened to that we want to know what
happened to that bmw you sold it i sold
it yeah
i'm trying yeah i sold that i'm trying
yeah
it was well no it no no it went
right down
uh before the m6 i had a hummer
h2 and i had a
when the challengers first came out of
challenger you have the picture of the
m6 bro you said you got the
type in two on six m6 that thing was
sick yeah
yeah me and me and jay was like oh it's
like that yeah it's that far right one
right yeah that one the black one yeah
no black on black yeah
well that goes hard as they were
cool man i know if he had a v10 in it
it was sick you swooped it up um
no oh okay they had a v10 it was sick
your first
big big car purchase yeah yeah yeah is
that what you that's what you were
saying uh that m6 is a big purchase
because i paid uh all cash for it
that was a big purchase especially
especially being a ufc fighter
i can't believe people let me do that
okay that's a bad bird it's just a bad
idea
oh yeah yeah
didn't you don't get a tesla is what
he's saying okay
i'm saying if you live in an apartment
because you don't have a charging
station yeah
you just you just one more hat it's a
hassle
what do you like well i like i like the
bmws i like small like fast cars
i like i like coupes you know like a
two-seater because it's like yo can i
get a ride
like nice i got like someone else with
me you know what i mean i like that kind
of car
yeah coops porsche career is a coupe
that is true but again he's not in that
bracket i know he is if you're in a
tesla you're in that bracket you use
koopa and that's thing about
porsches they're reliable is
they're dope they handle way better than
teslas they're not going to be as fast
but also tesla's they eat gas they do it
they know they're flat sixes they get
great gas mileage oh yeah great gas
mileage
and
hold up that's a brand that's a brand
new that's a 20 21 go to like 911 and
that's a convertible you don't want to
convert this
give me like a 2016 let me see what two
things no
you know even a 2014. all right let me
just see
hold on oh okay
okay but i want to use when that's
that's brand new oh that's brand new
for what for
let's just 2014. yeah yeah if you do
that show me the car i bet you get one
look at that it still looks that's that
is that that's the ass
now that's the s though i'm not i'm not
working if you're in that bracket go off
i'm not home i'll let you fly dog you
know what i'm saying
red bull give me bro come on now
again i would love something like that
scroll to grateful for it
i mean i bet i bet we could find one for
50.
now we're talking you following
something like 50 in my oh
we could easily do that hey okay look i
like this i like that
i like that black one okay and the black
really sick say list
2014 off the l but it's not the s though
and it has 50 000 miles on it that's
pretty good
[Music]
50k comes with some miles
that's a horse so we're not too worried
about it
oh you know what you want if you want a
dope ride for a good price that's newer
too and has like great engine
engineering mercedes they hold value
like but also
they're a terrible value i'll tell
people about dope cars and they get
as soon as you drive a mercedes lot
unless it's a g wagon
as soon as you drive off a lot cuts in
half yeah
half probably half but you get like a
new s-class
gee but but you could get a dope-ass uh
e-class you get a dope there's a
little we got options well i don't like
you like that big body you like that uh
the the
the uh was it the e63 amg
is ridiculous that's a four door
you got this but if you like coop what
about an m4
i love what's talking about the m4s as
well two thousand yeah jay likes uh
small small cars yeah he i don't like
small cars why why not
i don't know you have a hole that my the
the porsche is not a small car
well hold on it's not like an m3 to me
would be a small car
a m2 would be a small car that's the
same size they're not the same size
the chassis is bigger it is yeah i don't
really fit m3s
listen that porsche you got that's a
small car yeah it's not a small car
okay wait time are you talking a small
car would be a boxster
okay i get m2 m3 m1 those are small
uh mini cooper a mini yes a little bit
of mini cooper well
many cookies aren't fun jay had a mini
cooper yeah
jay had a mini cooper i had mini cooper
it was so much fun what happened to your
mini cooper uh
can i meet you in a mini cooper yeah i
used to drive a mini cooper when i first
started working for you guys and then i
drove that until the wheels fell off
they're dope right my body used and it
was fun
right oh first of all bmw makes
them
so much fun to drive it's like a really
fast go-kart that's great on gas
and you can park anywhere in l.a i'm
just saying you like smart cars
nobody want a honda crx
that was my mom first car a subaru sti
is dope
prelude we'll get you a soup subaru a
mini cooper is a dope ass right there's
one right across the street i know
you're a cheap ass lease on one right
now you would you
yeah now listen are any girls to want to
you in that mini cooper
no again i don't care a lot of pantyhose
that looks like me
hard body hard body that doesn't
like
that does look dope like the uk
version of chapel
yeah bruv i'm in the community yeah
they're done mini coopers are dope
damn look we'll go go jay just got rid
of his he did
he did not tell me we was over there
looking at cars and stuff oh yeah that
could be you
couldn't imagine jay fitting in a mini
cooper yeah like you're pretty spacious
inside they are if it's just you and
maybe one other person very spacious
yeah depending on the size of the other
person
you don't have a family malik so it's
not i mean who gives a yeah you're
right i want to enjoy life you're right
again i don't know those new corvettes
my friend got those that's a hundred
thousand dollar car um
you get an old z06 that'd be sick yeah i
i looked at that those
well that's like 72 000. okay okay so
they tell the search dude the testing
is the tesla cheap the tesla is
affordable
no the one the ones that allen has yeah
are you talking about the two-door
we're talking about the coupe yeah the
two-door the small ones
they look like a bumblebee oh these are
stupid wait what no i mean what do they
look like oh i'll show you oh the
roadster
the roaster is that what that's not
available this one no way no not this
one
that again that's caleb that's brian's
i'm not the one before that chin
look 36 39 000 yeah it's cheap we look
trust me
my research show me the tesla's you
typed it in
i know hey we're going to get you a
picture dog
i appreciate you man well no not that
that's not again a surprise
oh wait look look the nah no no no the
the more
you know it looks more like uh yeah oh i
know you're talking yeah yeah
falcon tesla right everything
because you can't say the r word anymore
you can't say that you can't say it
so i i supplement that with peanut
butter peanut butter falcon
you call that a peanut butter that's
tesla that's that's that's actually
probably that's
it that's suv and also the suv is cheap
yep the suvs aren't bad yeah they're
cool come on man
it's like a mix between this and the car
yeah it's just like that
yeah unless something like that yes hey
you could buy
uh they don't have like i'm saying you
don't have a charging station man
okay you're constantly searching around
you're right well i don't
i'll just drive to the podcast like
brian's asked to be like i'm like where
yeah i'd be like i'm at this charging
station
yeah how about that when i get off stage
at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this front
of a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
together come on
i'm just saying dude grab that mic son